i'm telling you this is the best thing
you'll ever have ever no
no no no no brooke what are you doing
obviously
young lady tomato sauce is the easiest
sauce in the world
i'm making a low-carb sandwich with
orange bell pepper and cream cheese
oh dude no it's not viral it's vile
kyle you can't spell stop it the nose oh
halloween
stop no my darling you've got the wrong
scott that looks like jerry butler
it's not canned soup no
no bang guys i'm going to be showing you
how to boujee
no cheese meal chef sheena there's no
such word
are you boozed up have you been drinking
girl or my granddad he died 10 years ago
[Music]
no microwave
no that is not a low-carb sandwich
young lady that there is an idiot
sandwich
a yolk nose add some sugar
no no
anna
[Music]
[Music]
there's nothing british about that in
the microwave are you kidding me
no plastic mac and cheese oh a fresh
onion
okay so we are going to unravel
[Music]
no right i just decided to open it all
and shove them in the oven i'll stop it
or the crunchy top here oh no come on
cheesy what sets come on
fish and treats you've never been to
britain eat mac and cheese i put it in
bell peppers
flour colin colin colin you're such a
bell end then add in your pot cook
oh my god
stop it no you are kidding me
that looks disgusting i'd rather eat one
of your plastic nails
disgusting really
dude you need to learn how to spell